et place à la folie maintenant sur
france 3 centre val de loire et le
facebook évidemment merci de nous
rejoindre pour le festival de terres du
son au sud de tours à nous sommes amont
au domaine de candé au coeur de la
nature avec maintenant donc les naïve
new beaters merci d'être avec tout
martin et david on salue aussi eurobelix
un qui n'est pas présent maintenant
alors à la folie c'est le nom de votre
troisième album qui vient juste de
sortir ce lundi un album qui semblerait
qu'ils soient nés dernière ce lundi
voilà c'est avec la relativité du temps
c'est comme s'il était sorti lé tout
juste l'india la folie dedans c'est
comme ça qu'il faut voir les choses
évidemment alors un album qui est un
album qui naît d'un constat simple dans
son blog ici puisque vous êtes retrouvés
tous les droits c'est tous les trois
célibataires et vous vous êtes dit ah on
fait un album gay simultanément et bah
du coup on s'est dit qu'est ce qui nous
reste bas la musique et donc on sait
fédérer autour de la musique j'étais
emprunter le mot fédérer justement veux
pas mais c'est vrai que j'aime quand les
fédérateurs et c'est vrai et même on
n'était même plus vraiment avec notre
label aussi donc tu veux c'était un
quadruple enfin pas vraiment largage
mais bon tu veux on s'est retrouvé face
à nous mêmes
c'était votre folie cet album qu'est ce
que ça représente pour vous finalement
la folie au quotidien mais au final de
la feuillée on l'a écrit sur pas mal de
temps avec plusieurs sessions un peu de
compos s éloigner donc au final au fil
de l'album bas c'est un peu les
différents étapes par lesquelles tu
passes après un gros changement ou une
rupture donc parfois baiia comme on dit
une vraie folie
parfois il ya une sorte de deux bennes
de folie plus mélancoliques parfois ben
on est boosté parfois on est des faux
dire qu'on a fait cet album
principalement dans le manoir de robes
helix qui est pas présent aussi mais qui
viendra ce soir je vous rassure
et donc on était tous les trois en
autarcie totale avec des besoins comme
les chercher du feu pour
se chauffer et donc on devenait un petit
peu fou au bout de quinze jours les 3
les uns sur les autres en voyant
personne d'autre que nous dire que la
mélancolie c'est une folie en fait
finalement abbès en fait partie une
folie douce disons mélancolie c'est bien
regarder la définition de la mélancolie
et c'est en fait c'est vraiment tu le
lis tu as l'impression que c'est la
définition de la dépression ah ouais
vraiment fait la mélancolie c'est hyper
profond je savais pas non plus on a
enjolivé ce mot mais c'est pas mal d'un
jolivet les mots parfois on fait la
mélancolie fun c'est un nouveau concept
avec les inévitables célibataire fondé
de lier à quelques instants mais sur
scène un peu moins puisque vous vous
êtes votre les défis qui sont présentes
notamment deux côtés à la basse et lucie
à la batterie des instruments qui sont
plutôt joué habituellement par des
garçons c'était aussi un message de se
dire que dans la musique il faut aussi
une parité c'est vrai et puis on est roi
mais qu'il ya deux films et deux filles
veulent bien trois mecs petits moments
de démagogie sur la parité voilà ce qui
nous met un tout les auditrices et
spectatrices de france 3 dans la
chaufferie inside the puck alors
d'ailleurs dans ce troisième album le
premier extrait c'est il tue mais qui
balaie aussi une femme
il a un fils du chanteur jacques higelin
comme vous l'avez choisie c'est une
vieille connaissance au fait n'est pas
vieille mais ça fait très longtemps
qu'on est potes avec elle via notre
tourneur je rends compte salut et on
avait un peu fait plusieurs
collaborations martin bang bang qu'on
avait joué avec elle à la cigale ou au
trianon je ne me souviens plus
exactement et on avait fait un morceau
sur une sorte de mixtapes album entre
deux albums qui s'appelait the guest
list et on avait fait ce titre il trop
et ce titre a été tourné avec une
technique bien particulière à 360 degrés
voilà le clip
qu'est ce que ça apporte finalement ce
tournage à 360° bad eu du fun j'aimerais
dire parce que je sais pas si vous avez
j'ai vu des clips à 360 degrés mais
souvent en toute objectivité on peut
considérer qu'ils sont un peu chiant et
donc du coup le nôtre enfin grâce au
réalisateur romain chassaing qui est un
grand talent talentueux réalisateur et
qui on a fait un autre clip et même deux
autres clips
il a réussi à faire un clip à 360 degrés
ou qu'on regarde il ya des choses
intéressantes à voir voit la
démonstration
j'ai regardé il ya des trucs à voir
voilà et en bas pareil exactement
donc je peux te dire que les clips de
bjork et compagnie up à la trappe piotta
là encore plus loin avec lui dans
l'équipe world of goo avec une
proposition artistique qui est assez
original puisqu'on a un sur internet sur
le site interne que je citais world of
trade unions lefilm.com ce clip devient
interactif
on peut choisir finalement la fin de ce
clip et de cette histoire en fait il est
même interactif sur youtube c'est même
pas que la fin qu'on peut choisir c'est
tout le déroulé c'est à dire à chaque
moment de la vie il ya quarante sept
scénarios possibles se mettre dans votre
peau
mais voilà c'est ça et puis à chaque
moment de la vie par exemple on est à
l'examen final est-ce qu'on doit tricher
ou ne pas tricher
enfin il ya plein d'autres moments de la
vie on doit tout dépend de sa conscience
en fait voilà alors vous êtes 3d trois
personnalités différentes on le voit là
et des goûts musicaux différents aussi
comment vous faites pour vous entendre
stop dessus et puis à la fin cela est il
impose son style non mais on essaye de
faire comme les mixologistes est un
cocktail équilibrée entre nos
différentes cultures musicales qui sont
assez marqué mais qu'on essaye de réunir
du mieux qu'on peut et de garder un bon
qu'un bon goût un peps et que c'est même
une jolie couleur c'est ça ah voilà ça
c'est aussi un cocktail c'est la fois
gustatif et visu
au final vous êtes toujours d'accord
vous taper toujours d'accord sur une
création c'est la façon de décider c'est
qu'on ne sort quelque chose on valide
quelque chose que si on est tous les
trois d'accord en tout cas c'est ce qui
s'est passé sur ce dernier album sont
les artistes qui vous influence moi
personnellement j'aime beaucoup les
artistes avec beaucoup de guitare à
l'intérieur ça peut aller de ac/dc des
trucs un petit peu plus on va dire
extrême mais ou alors de l'électronique
les daft punk par exemple je pense que
c'est une bonne inspiration vous david
mois je souhaiterais quand même maxime
sperissen bakounine quand même parce que
c'est gbagbo déjà les morceaux j'adore
et bon scéniquement à chaque fois
c'était complètement fou ils ont tous
des personnalités pareil et puis les
dans les clips baïse innover pas mal
voilà puis brest et coulisses prenez pas
au sérieux en même temps ils
s'assuraient grave sort justement vous
n'avez pas vous prendre au sérieux sur
scène mais vous allez assurer évidemment
sans aucun doute son festival terres du
son c'est là la première fois fait que
vous y participer c'est vrai c'est la
première fois que j'y participe
il fait une chaleur hallucinante mais on
est au coeur d'un espace vert très
agréable je sais pas si vous avez vu le
château du domaine de condé juste à
l'entrée de ce festival qui est un
festival ambassadeur on va dire de la
solidarité du développement durable ce
sont des valeurs en fait dans lesquelles
vous reconnaissez tous les deux alors on
n'y avait pas pensé me sens qu'une fois
qu'on a fait une interview on avait dit
qu'on voulait faire un clip écologique
alors je sais pas encore exactement un
clip biodégradables je sais pas encore
quelle forme ça va prendre exactement
vous savez qu'il ya tout ce qu'il faut
ici à des toilettes sèches par exemple
j'étais aux toilettes sèches et pendant
que j'étais quelqu'un retirer le bac qui
se trouve derrière c'était hyper gênant
alors une première fois ça l'est mais
quand cinq minutes après enfin ben il
est revenu et me l'a redit bon là ça
devenait vraiment millions peut-être que
ça va vous vous inspirer pour ce
prochain clip
en tout cas le rapport développement
durable c'est que d'une certaine manière
on a parlé de la jeunesse de l'album on
s'était fait larguer donc on avait des
sentiments et
et sans cesse pas terrible et on à
recycler ses sensations en bonnes
sensations musicales sensations
musicales avant et après un concert
aussi parce que c'est ce que l'on a vu
tout à l'heure vous étiez en train de
jouer là où au frisbee c'est votre
manière de vous préparez-vous oui oui je
vous ai vu vous vous laissez pas vous
étiez vous n'étiez pas juste derrière
moi pour vous fait ça juste avant voilà
bah on avait un frisbee par terre on
s'est dit mais atteint mais que ça se
fait comment jour et tu vois on a joué
savent aussi que dans le camion on a une
console un petit peu rétro qui nous
permet de jouer à des vieux jeux il ya
un jeu qu'on affectionne tout
particulièrement qui s'appelle
windjammer qui est un jeu de frisbee
aussi bizarre que cela puisse paraître
donc là on voit qu'en vrai c'est quand
même beaucoup moins spectaculaire qu'à
l'écran on verra ça mais je veux faire
avec vous on y va c'est parti allez on
se retrouve un peu plus tard évidemment
sur facebook france 3 centre val de
loire pour terres du son est donc ce
soir quand même il faut rappeler que
vous êtes ici sur cette seule à 22h30
jusqu'à 23h45 pour découvrir votre
univers les naïve new beaters qu'est ce
que ça veut dire d'ailleurs
on ne sait pas c'est une pure invention
aussi on le saut soir 22h30 sur la scène
terres de son frustre pe
radio derrière d'accord
n'a rien à faire ici
on fera du frisbee plus tard parce que
évidemment messieurs la vallée se
reposer ouais on fera ça plus tard merci
d'avoir été avec nous portez vous bien
à bientôt merci